Trump supporters around the country
continue to face an onslaught of public
shaming just this week President Trump
smacking down Will & Grace star Debra
Messing for saying his donors should be
outed and now we have another outrageous
example get this you have a liberal
author taking to Twitter to tell people
to avoid wearing any type of red hat
quote is anyone else made really
uncomfortable these days by anyone
wearing any kind of red baseball cap
like the st. Louis Cardinals how's the
other thing maybe they don't wear red
caps anymore normal people also for the
love of God the clever folks wearing
make America read again or whatever caps
no you're making everyone scared don't
do it banning red caps is this an idea
whose time has come
Jessie waters are so soft kill me I mean
they can't handle a hat they get upset
when you eat a hamburger they don't want
you to drive somewhere they want to make
sure your house is properly insulated
stay out of my house and my kitchen
stay out of my closet right you know
they're always saying say out of our
bedroom we'll get out of my closet
hey I can't wear my Phillies cap because
it's gonna trigger some liberal come on
Meghan does this kind of ridiculousness
but it's really over the top really
bring people back down to earth and make
it realize we're overreacting so they're
angry about red hats so by extension
they hate Santa Claus yes and I I
wouldn't want to make anybody from
Philadelphia wearing we're already makes
me more frightened Red Sox fans whoo do
not bring on the wrath of a resolution
okay this is which the Redskins
are you triggered when you see a red cap
your sports fan well I'm a big
Washington Nationals fan so you know
we're staying on the Washington
Nationals we wear red hats in fact
they've been the Capitals have a thing
about get your red on in Washington
so I mean to me this is kind of nuts but
do I understand what she's saying yes I
do because I think there are lots of
people who like to troll liberals and I
think they're other people who don't
even perceive that that hat that make
America great again had what it says to
people of color what it says to
immigrants what it says to a lot of
women in this
it's threatening do you how is that
threatening it's a hat
are you kidding the kind of intolerance
the kind of things that we've seen take
place in this country
everything from the from Charlotte's
America great again forget the practice
it's not the politics it's that you are
intentionally sending a very divisive
message with some people don't even
perceive it they don't understand how I
would take your latter point Emily I
don't think people perceive it the way
one perceives it well clearly that one
woman does look I'm all for limiting
Niners gear and wazoo Gerrits but I to
me I'm like you know what keep it up
keep it up because all this is going to
do is galvanize everyone else because
now it's being over into the normal
fandom who are like what are you talking
about and to me the hypocrisy again of
Hollywood where everyone they're all the
actors have in their little Twitter BIOS
I'm an activist and then what's her face
Debra Messing she tweeted out a black
vote for Trump is mental illness she
later apologized but if if I were to say
that on the show exactly the and somehow
there is it has it occurred to you that
he says keep a make America great again
and now keep America great that he's
talking about the eight years of
President Obama and the apology tour and
the acquiescence on the world stage and
the retraction of the American Dream and
pride around the globe not a back to
slavery and pre Civil War talk either
courtesy I think is back to 1950s and
women and their places but actually he
has never said that I think you see this
as controlling I think again we're an
American family we're a community of
people actually I don't think that we
should be intentionally offending
somebody just Excel you know I had some
fun I really gave it to Jesse you know
it's do that's at some point that's
juvenile but that's what you're bringing
to the table you think that somebody
wearing a mag ahead because they voted
for President Trump is doing it to
offend you steaming pile of horse hooey
and you know it no I don't I just told
you how I felt big and that's that was
legit but now but you're right but now
that people know
it upsets people when they see a Red Hat
like you said earlier about the
hamburgers they're just gonna wear there
that's why I think we got two that was
the Whoopi Goldberg was a breaking point
I think people are gonna start
respecting people my hope is from here
on and say just because we vote
differently we're not got a boycott it's
gonna stop right here
that's my hope nobody believes me but